galastine welcome to play today my name
is maximos and today three women are
going to be cooking me souvlaki I can't
wait
I'm not 100 Greek my father is half my
mother is full my mother's family comes
from Crete my father's family comes from
northern ipiros when I'm looking for
somebody to date I think I really look
towards like the connection we have I
think chemistry is really important
aside from that I also think a loyalty
and a willingness to eat anything you
cook that's that's really like the two
standards I kind of live by the
welcoming nature is something that's
been instilled in us since birth that's
why I love our culture we're taught to
love in every way and it's beautiful I'm
from from Columbus Ohio and being Greek
is a huge part of my life my dad's side
is from Crete and my mom's side is from
not factos growing up Greek was
literally like the movie My Big Fat
Greek Wedding thanksgivings consisted of
70 plus people and a guy I am looking
for someone who is like light-hearted
funny definitely sarcastic dressed sense
of humor good banter that's key
obviously I'm not picky at all
I am cooking chicken souvlakia on a pita
I'm first just gonna start with the
fries so I can get those in the oven the
olive oil is a hundred percent from
Greece and it's actually from Crete
where my family is from which was cool I
started out with marinating this for 24
hours and then roasting it in the oven I
am now gonna cut up some Tomatoes red
onions and then sprinkle some feta this
is homemade Suzuki there's so much love
in this my entire heart is this now I'm
gonna add some red onions and then we
will add some heirloom tomatoes and I'll
just add some fries I definitely want
the bright flavors to come forward this
is my bright and bold chicken soup like
yeah okay and off the bat I'm already
excited because they have french fries
in here you can already tell that this
person doesn't mind grease dribbling
down the the chin good I love that
lovely he seems a little by the book but
it's in a good way this person and me
would automatically get off on the right
foot oh
I could tell that they're independent
based on how they made this is this true
this person is somebody that is
always unfolding themselves I'm gonna
use that on my dating all right
for a second bite I can tell this
person's a lot of fun to be around
the meat's tender and good and I can
tell that again
I feel like they had a lot of fun when
preparing this dish it was fun this is
the type of person you'd want to have
after church on a Sunday making your
food having Cafe they're the type of
homebody that you really really like to
warm up next to spicy materials so sweet
I'm originally from Long Island New York
on my mom's side I'm from Sparta and on
my dad's side I'm from Crete growing up
my nanny actually cooked and she's
originally from Greece too and the man
I'm looking for is someone who's loyal
goofy very loving towards me I would say
very family oriented and all around like
a fun good like genuine person to be
around I used pork and I marinated that
for about 10 to 20 minutes and I just
pan fried that up so I'm making the
Greek salad it's always red onion and
green bell pepper this is a lot of fun
though I'm gonna put a little bit of
lemon some olive oil and season it in
Greece you can get to Souvlaki literally
anywhere wherever you go the beach like
side of the street like a nice
restaurant like a more fast food
restaurant you can get it literally
anywhere I'm an esthetician so I love to
make things look pretty I think that's
cute little dollop of oil this is my
zesty pork Souvlaki it looks beautiful
it seriously this is somebody who's
organized off the bat you can already
talk organize it so this person left the
dish customizable towards what I'd want
they left it very very open for me to
add certain things like that that'siki
or the vegetables and again to me that's
really somebody who cares a lot about
the other person's feelings
I really really think this person uh has
a mothering Spirit you know
so good you guys hey let's go so in
Greek pork is cute you know hirino
Souvlaki is really really hard because
it can get really tough sometimes this
person we call it zoomi it's the sauce
it's the fatty sauce that dribbles off
the meat this person
it reminds me a lot of my mother wow
yeah wow it tastes like home like can I
get another bite yeah
I'm from Athens Greece I was born and
raised there and my dad is Greek and my
mom's Ukrainian I loved living in Athens
we have a break every day for a nap and
the afternoon for three hours people
just go home from their work and nap I
just love that aspect of my culture in
one word I would describe myself as
complicated but in a good way
what I look for in a man as honesty
trust and humor today I made hirino
karamaki which is pork on a stick inside
the pita bread we call it which means
Village salad so I'm just gonna put some
olive oil on the pita we'll put the
Tzatziki
Tomatoes
if I had to describe my dish I would say
it's delicious authentic and straight
from Greece this is my perfect pork soup
I could sit and eat these all day yeah
exactly this is somebody who can
unapologetically feed you what they want
to make you and you will eat it and it
will be good that is who this person is
somebody who is so ingratiating and
welcoming that they're able to share
themselves that is really sweet yeah I
think at one point in ancient Greece it
was law if strangers came to your door
you had to invite them in and you had to
welcome them and you had to feed them
because that by nature is who we are as
a people we are a welcoming breed I
think this person is somebody who
embodies
a common phrase for our people's okay
they are our freedom deck somebody who
is selfless
and at some points again you wanna
be vulnerable with this person oh
no oh gosh
he's contemplating he's like just that
was a really good piece of meat okay
wow
this is somebody who could make me
really happy just by being near me and I
I it was proven by that fight that's
sweet that is very sweet that's a good
good compliment so the first dish which
was the Chicken Souvlaki I thought that
was a person who is feisty is fine you
go on adventures with again grease
dribbling down the chin kind of good
second one was neat and organized and
very very caring and considerate and
that again just warmed you up and then
the last one was just somebody who knew
the Simple Pleasures somebody who
understood just that an olive could make
a world of difference I
this is hard I think he's gonna pick me
up
because I added the Greek olives
straight from Greece they're authentic
straight off the boat but I also believe
in you I think it's gonna pick you
because men do like
their mothers I think he talked about
you with a lot of passion yeah but he
was like passionate about the food not
the personality the personality it's
yours he was like really getting into
your like what this girl's like yeah the
winner is number three Mary Lou thank
you so much for that wonderful meal
thank you
hi hi
legitimately when I saw the olives out
there I'd like that was it that was what
did it for me I was like somebody who
could just bring me a plate of feta and
oil I'm good that's all I need I feel
that listen I'd really love to take you
out on a date if you want I have a
reservation at avra that sounds
fantastic
that was fun
[Music]